just look at her hands in my hands
that's the difference here I've been
making cakes for eight years how is this
a contest well brie has the techniques
but does she have the creativity I don't
think so I am a professional cake
decorator and owner of Brees cakes here
in Los Angeles
I've maybe made like three cakes in my
life I have been drawing my whole life I
don't feel as confident I think at least
the colors will be nice I've been really
confidence I do this every day let's do
it all right
wait their roles what kind of roles okay
okay
that that's yeah that's okay
[Music]
oh okay good so I decided for my sweet
16 cake to do very vibrant colors cuz if
I was 16 again I'd want bright colors
like pink and purple and blue so I'm
gonna take all those colors make a
striped buttercream and then top it with
a fondant bow so today I'm gonna be
making a cake inspired by my favorite
book the little prince and I'm gonna
make the cake look like a meteor then
I'm gonna make a little rose made out of
fondant it's gonna be great it's not as
easy as it looks is it awful No are you
supposed to need it like this I don't
know no I don't know your hands are
gonna get died oh it's for all right
you're like my competition right now I
can't tell you everything oh I'm not
here to win I'm here to make friends I
am a hundred percent self-taught and I
taught myself how to make cakes from
watching TV shows like Cake Boss and Ace
of Cakes I used to YouTube a lot and
just kind of googled things and Here I
am eight years later and now I own a
baby
so I'm gonna do something really crazy
uh-oh are you gonna cut it
I've never shaved a cake like this
before it's really hard it's very risky
of you to do that
yeah I'm a risk taker you're a whisk
taker with taker you're welcome
the story of the little princes there's
this little kid that lives on a planet
called asteroid b16 and he falls in love
with a rose that grows on his planet and
then I take a deep breath
[Music]
I'm really happy with it I'm happy that
the colors didn't bleed together and
that the border stayed structurally
sound and the bow is standing up without
collapsing
this is asteroid b16 which is like 16th
birthday so it makes sense it's thematic
it was an accident but worked out it was
a messy process you could see that on
the hands and the table I think it came
together pretty well now I guess
strangers are gonna come in and judge
our cakes do we have to be here with a
judge or can we like leave you know guys
I didn't have a sweet 16 just because
I'm really bad at planning but I would
have loved for either be used to be my
cake this one definitely sells a sweet
16 so I'm about the color isn't like
there's a bow on top so it's almost like
a present or a package this cake I think
is a slightly cooler to me just because
it's weirder is this like a Beauty and
the Beast thing I don't really know I
mean I think this one represents the
theme better
I am super impressed I do not know whose
is whose
this one though I have to say it's my
favorite it's rainbow it just looks like
I want to put in my mouth right now so
we're my sweet 16 which I really wish it
was I would take the weird one
for like a 16 year old girl I would
think that this is what she would want
this is what I would want I like this
one this is the cake I want to cut into
on camera in front of all my friends an
Instagram later
thank you to the people congratulations
what do I win yay look at my trophy it
says bragging rights
the little prince is kind of an obscure
reference and I kind of made it for
myself like a selfish artist oh this is
going up on a shelf in my bakery can we
eat them No
[Music]